es ist ja ein wesentliches argument der
regierung dass der antrag der pakt
annehmbare sei weil er doch so
unverbindlich sei wir haben darauf
hingewiesen in unserem primär antrag in
der letzten plenarwoche wo wir
eingefordert haben das nicht zu
unterzeichnen das die gefahr die
standardmäßig gegebene gefahr besteht
dass der internationale pakt völker
gewohnheitsrecht wird um dem zu entgehen
ist es notwendig in der internationalen
ebene schriftlich eine erklärung dazu
protokoll zu geben die den berühmten
online dinge charakter den rechtlich
nicht bindenden charakter nicht nur für
jetzt sondern auch für zukünftig fest
schreibt dass dadurch also auch
fürderhin kein internationales recht
begründet wird es ist ja so dass die
wortwahl impact bewusst rechtlich
unscharf ist schon der begriff pakt ist
non standard für die erklärungen der
vereinten nationen die nicht
völkerrechtliche verträge sind die von
allen parlamenten hätten ratifiziert
werden müssen üblicherweise heißt dass
resolution und nicht packt man begibt
sich bewusst in die völkerrechtliche
grauzone des sogenannten soft law was
dann nach der annahme nach einigen
jahren wie wir darauf hingewiesen haben
mutiert zu anerkannten völker
gewohnheitsrecht eine weitere bewusst
eingegangen eine begriffliche unschärfe
im text des paktes ist dass er die
unterscheidung zwischen legal und
illegal vermeidet und sie herüber
definieren will in das begriffspaar
regulär und irregulär dass keine
anerkannten rechtsbegriffe sind wir
stellen weiterhin fest dass die im zu
beginn des verhandlungsprozesses von
einem mitglied des akademie academy
council of the united nations ist ihm
bewusst bekundete worden ist dass die
ganzen regeln globaler migrationsfragen
leiden an ein
lakoff enforcement an einem mangel an
rechtlicher umsetzungskraft und das
gelte es zu überwinden und dafür seien
global compact globale packte im
unterschied zur resolution das probate
mittel
das sei also eine neue modell für
internationales long making gesetzgebung
durch einen dynamischen politischen
prozess so dass die schließlich als
völkerrecht verankert werden können nun
um das zu verhindern ist die protokolle
erklärung das probate rechtliche mittel
auch nach auskunft des
wissenschaftlichen dienst des deutschen
bundestages ist es genau diese option
die möglich und nötig ist um zu
verhindern dass rechtliche software
konstruktion nach einer gewissen zeit
ablauf völker gewohnheitsrecht werden
das einem dann hier wie der national
entgegengehalten werden kann mit der
kolle protokollerklärung wird dem
entgegengewirkt und wenn es jetzt heißt
auch von herrn schäuble der pakt
enthielte ja keine verpflichtungen zu
denen wir nicht ohnehin verpflichtet
sein ich erinnere nur daran dass er
ausdrücklich erklärt man verpflichtet
sich migration zu erleichtern und zu
gewährleisten bitte migration an sich
dort ist nicht mehr bezug genommen auf
asylfälle auf schutzstatus subsidiärer
schutz oder so etwas und es heißt dass
der pakt durch koordiniertes
grenzmanagement sichere und reguläre
grenzübertritte gewährleisten will
sanktionen gegen illegale zuwanderer
sollen überprüft und revidiert werden ob
sie nicht diskriminierend sein
dieser antrag ist also das was auch
österreich macht die aufforderung zur
abgabe bei denen ist es die abgabe der
protokollerklärung so dass selbst bei
annahme wie im fall deutschlands der
pakt keine bindungswirkung war
völkerrecht bekommen kann
da man sich zum sogenannten permanent ob
sektor erklärt was die frage einer
späteren rückwirkung angeht